with drake specifically hip-hop is
culture
it's lingo it's style it's cuisine it's
fashion everything about it is the
flavor
feel me the flavor
it's like you know what i mean it's like
soulful it's like
like yes like the concept of fried
chicken initially could be sold for
right that don't mean kentucky fried
chicken sell soul food
they got greens that don't mean they
sell soul food they got all this stuff
that don't mean they sell soul food
was popularized by hip-hop but it is not
exclusive debbie harry was rapping in
the [ __ ] century saying drake makes
rap music not but he's not hip-hop no i
i think that he's not a cultured rapper
he has no culture he doesn't represent
any culture drake is a fantastic rapper
who makes fantastic rap songs that turn
into pop songs and he can sing his
[ __ ] ass off the way he sings he he
can uh carry a note
only the way he can he makes fantastic
records non-stop is one of my favorite
[ __ ] records period
femi but again to compare him to
somebody that's carrying the burden of
culture on their back like a jay-z or
snoop these dudes represent entire
realms of worlds of [ __ ]
i mean ideals all of this they
represented with the way they talk the
way they speak everything about what
they're doing they're they're walking
with more drake is a i mean i don't want
to simplify his plife because i'm sure
he had his own struggles but this is a
kid that comes from nickelodeon that's a
rapper what you know i mean it's just a
different plight this [ __ ] came from a
dope spot this [ __ ] came from feel me
long beach cripping
the plights are different